welcome to serious jibber-jabber I'm
here with my friend Jack White who's
phenomenal solo album blunderbuss is his
first number-one record it's been
nominated for three Grammy Awards Jack
nice to have you here nice to have me
here yeah it's very good to be seen with
you and to have you in this strange
chamber
I like this chamber you've built yeah I
built this yourself - I did I was up
yeah it took me four days to build this
it's made of pure asbestos um you'll be
dead in a year uh welcome to the show
thanks for have you could even call this
a show I was thinking about today I got
a lot of people that ask me this about
the time we met and I thought it was
probably a good place to start
yeah uh beginning the beginning I was
all I remember is I think it's the late
90s I fly to Detroit to shoot a crazy
video with Ted Nugent I think at his
farm where we shot guns and rode around
on three-wheeled vehicles and then at
the end of the shoot I come back to the
hotel and we all go play we see a
bowling alley yeah we go bowling and
that's where you and Meg came over and
how long had the White Stripes been
around at that point we were just
probably just starting at that point I
mean we were just kind of fumbling
around it was a thought that wadis this
really this band could really work and I
don't think Milly Meg was convinced at
the moment cuz it was so simple it's the
sort of thing you might think all people
might think this is foolish or something
but we were trying to be childish on
purpose so I think we just started
kicking around at the beginning then
kicking around and you're in Detroit
yeah and you had been an upholsterer yes
and you take a pull string very
seriously
I apologize because you offered to
upholster the chair for the Conan show
this show that offers still standing and
I didn't take you seriously I didn't I
thought you were kidding no I mean it
and then later on it I thought you were
serious I'll do it I'll still do it all
right
let's doing what we do a whole new chair
all right a pollster my chair for me I
like that I'll do it um
what about upholstering has helped you
in your musical career the most
important part about it was it was a
moment when I was a Prentice upholsterer
how old were you at the time I was about
15 I think 15 or 16 and there was a
mid-century modern couch with like a
vladimir Kagan piece I think I know I
had pink fabric with silver threads in
it and I it was tempted in the back it
was three staples in the back just to
keep it in place while the poster was
working in front of it and I just kept
staring at this over and over again I
was cleaning up sweeping up and working
on it and I skip steering it that's the
minimum amount of staples to hold that
piece of fabric down
that's now we can call that upholstered
you know what would be the minimum you
couldn't do it with two you could do on
the ends the middle would be right now I
just thought my brain is the middle a
table can only it could have three legs
and still stand but two it'll fall so
that sort of image has been burned into
my brain I think about that probably
once a week that image of that those
three staples and it's affected
everything I I forced myself to do
anything that I create artistically
music-wise whatever it is I force it
through the funnel of that idea you know
and I have three lines or three concepts
in a song or I wrap it around
storytelling and melody and rhythm the
white stripes the whole band was based
on the number three yeah so it's really
about it's about simplicity and not it's
almost like it's almost like a concept
of minimalism right when you say in some
way like not anything more than you
absolutely need well you have to be
careful when you do things like that
because there's there's this element of
pretension that I think other people
there's two ways about it one way was
that it can be pretentious if you take
it too seriously
if you become whatever pedantic about it
but I looked at it as a way of limiting
myself so that I could create more
things create more songs because I'm so
boxed in my brain is forced to work with
the tools that are at hand I think I I
can't let some engineers fix it or let
the three other members in the band
cover it up with what they're playing
whatever I am in this box by myself for
me and megger in this box
so I'm not we have to work and I still
do this no matter what I do even if I
have a song you know there's seven
people backing me up or something
I'm still thinking about that for myself
where my head lays in the music or in
the piece to keep myself boxed in any
time I give myself free rein all the
time all the money whatever everything
in front of me I I it is not good for me
and it makes me disinterested I remember
I was a people asking like when you when
you write songs I didn't I don't I write
songs when there's a task to do when
there's a job we have a studio time
books tomorrow and you know now what I
do is I have my own studio so I'll have
people coming like you know maybe next
week are the peacocks the gals are
becoming a record so the night before or
maybe I will force myself to write songs
because they're coming tomorrow I have
no choice I have nothing for them to
record I have to write songs now if I
said well I'll write some songs and when
I'm done with them I'll call you guys
and show up it won't happen
I just it was one there's a famous
saying that Samuel Johnson wrote the
dictionary cuz he needed to pay his rent
right he had it was the rents due in a
week he'd be like all right I'll give
you a dictionary and there is something
to that comfort kills can kill an
artistic impulse you have to I mean yeah
what what good can come from comfort I
mean it's not gonna be art you know I
mean I think there's a there's a false
ideal out there to some people maybe in
younger people they might think you know
I could be an artist and I don't have to
work and but I think like calling
yourself an artist you you have to work
three times as hard is someone with a
punch clock job because if you punch in
you have a responsibility at your job
but you have to you can also do what
you're told and and and work the machine
whatever you're doing and do what's
there already there for you do what
you're told to do it was expected of you
have that job but if you're an artist
and you have to create something from
nothing you know there's nothing on this
canvas
nothing on this tape we have to create
something that didn't exist before
that's that's ultra responsibility super
responsibility is not so here's the
question it's not 1998 anymore you're
not in Detroit facing a choice between
making it music or upholstering for the
rest of your life you're now at a stage
where you could be seen as comfortable
how do you create the situation where
you're not comfortable how do you create
the situation where you are up against
it now it's really up to me there's
really up to me to push myself and be
harder on myself it's not up to me now
to say oh you know I'm gonna record on
Pro Tools and let someone else fix it if
there's mistakes and I go I fix it with
a mouse and use some program to tune it
or whatever I really got to push myself
to not take it easy and not take any
kind of creature comforts of that
scenario especially now as you know it
was being in the White Stripes half the
half the trouble was out there there was
only me and Meg there was so little a
little amount of components involved a
half the work was done to keep it simple
but now I'm if you have a bit I have two
bands now and two with me how said
keeping my brain in that box is a lot
more work but I like that it's not you
know
that's a far cry from having writer's
block or not knowing to do with myself I
I know there's a lot of work on the
table for me to do whenever I feel like
it and I always feel like it because I
want to I want to create something every
day every day when I wake up that's what
I want to do it's not busy work it's not
anal retentive behavior and it's like I
cannot wait to catch up to this idea I
had three weeks ago that I haven't
gotten to do yet and I got adducing I
will say the selfish part of it is that
in music you can do that and like in
film if you're an actor or director
you're at the mercy of bigger teams you
know studio paying for it they could set
it up scheduling all that I can go out
and record in the studio and if it
doesn't turn out well I don't have to
put it out and I can throw it away and
start over again so there is a
selfishness to that world where I can I
can create every day because I because I
want to not to answer to anybody and I
don't don't take that lightly I take
that
I respect that is there anything about
this because you grew up very Catholic I
mean a very very Catholic very Catholic
family big family and there is sometimes
I sense and maybe it's spent a little
bit of guilt I was chained you know what
it is it's a you got to work for it it's
that feeling that you always need to
earn it you always need to end it is
ingrained in Catholicism that that you
don't you dismiss praise it's just stuff
it syndicates in your bone marrow people
say congratulations thanks let's put
that aside you've got to get to work in
it and that that's always yeah the sense
do you feel like that's something that
probably got in your DNA a little bit I
guess we have a job you know if you if
you're raised in any kind of faith or
beliefs or even political beliefs you
know you get to a point when you're an
adult and you have to assess how much of
that you want to let still exist in your
brain and dictate how you live your life
and religion is the toughest of all
those because if you really have
questions that reach outside the bounds
of the religion you were raised and you
you've really got problems you know and
and but as you're talking about like the
things on the side of it like saying
just even from being a big Catholic
family if you have that many people in
the house or that many people older than
you you've got to determine what as
you're older what what of those guilt
trips that you were given or those
lessons you were taught and anything
that you learned it was beautiful or
terrible which of it do you listen to
whichever do you keep going in your life
what do I do with my kids now we're not
I'm trying to teach them something and
and I catch myself doing you know giving
my kid a guilt trip or something it's
the ultra Catholic wave of you know
raising somebody and and sometimes I'm
I'm you know it's a good thing though I
mean that actually works or there's
times where actually makes sense you
know I don't have didn't dismiss it
completely hundred percent I never
useful it's funny because it's there for
a reason
there was a reason that that some of
these rules were put in place I think
it's very mid late twentieth century to
debunk it all yeah and you think
actually the
the thing that I happiest for that I
think I got maybe from my parents maybe
from Catholicism or whichever way that I
was raised for being from a large family
as I got this idea this were Catholic I
like to work really hard and I believe
in hard work and I think that's the
hardest thing I believe in talent yeah
and clearly you're someone who's got
talent but I think talent is overrated I
think I think talents important but the
real accelerant the real coefficient
that's the mystery number that makes the
whole thing work is hard hard yeah
freaking work any of any of your ideals
and I'm guessing in that and any of my
idols and you look back and you and you
see the things they've done the footage
and the recordings or the writings or
whatever it is you'll see these people
hard at work and even if they have
things where they have an obsession or
they have some kind of mental problem
whatever what's happening is them
working consistently and over and over
again and we were talked about Johnny
Carson oh yeah I mean nobody he was so
well read he read every book I mean how
do you have time to read that many books
with a busy schedule as you have you
know and because you're you're just
obsessed with pushing yourself pushing
yourself forward I'm reading a Steve
Martin's autobiography right now yeah
and this is thing been going on lately
and it's a you know playing live shows
around the world and there's a sting
going on with audiences now and it's
happening in Australia in Europe in
America and these crowds are just like
finishing songs and nobody's clapping
it's it's very strange it's sort of like
oh you know what's going on here and I
don't use a set list and I'm very
off-the-cuff onstage so I've always felt
about myself that I'm I'm like a
stand-up comedian shì I treat the
scenario exactly like they do every time
I hear a stand-up comedian talk about
his craft what he's doing like oh that
comedian was ripping off my jokes and
they were taking my material or I did
this joke and it bombed I took it out of
the set the next joke I told murdered
that's exactly how I play music on stage
you know and if the song if I if no one
claps I could they're too cool to clap
they say if you're in a scenario where
some hipster thing where they're not too
cool to clap we don't yeah
love the show but they're not gonna you
know they're lying to me do you mean
like a community if you tell us a great
joke it's be people aren't like too cool
to like let you can't help you so if you
laugh right so but people can you decide
if they want to clap or not and so if
they're lying to me like they they like
this song but they didn't clap for I
have no idea what to do with the next
song I know no my next move is a
comedian knows what his next move is
immediately you know well you think I
think they don't understand that that
that you're that you need them they
exactly and the thing is yes you if
people go and see Jack white they're in
control they have but they don't know
that they have no idea that you're
getting anything I hand out pamphlets
before every show I just have gotten
those pamphlets please please enjoy me
it's exactly one talking it's really the
saddest pamphlet I've ever read a rock
show um but I tell you a rose reading
the Steve Martin biography the
autobiography and and I think in the
foreword he says the on stage when I was
a stand-up comedian there was no time
for enjoyment there's no time you need
to enjoy myself I'm too busy thinking
about the next move and I think that's
exactly how I feel all the time I never
on stage sit and like yes this is great
and I feel the whole song for the whole
time
I'm loving this and then a minute like I
passed three seconds of that feeling I
it just just starts to dissipate and
disappear for me I have to like shake it
off and push forward and move or even if
the song is fraught with mistakes or
problems if I know in my brain I'm
pushing forward and not sitting there
laughing having a blast I know I'm
getting somewhere somehow somewhere well
there's a you know I don't think about
the way the instruments you choose you
go out of your way to play instruments
that are hard to play that are hard to
keep in tune yeah uh have you ever
wanted to give in and say I just want to
go get myself a killer amazing the
callings that just plays like butter you
know what I mean the temptation comes up
all the time and it's a tough it's a
tough thing to know and see your peers
doing those things and nobody cares the
musicians don't really care that much
then the crowd definitely doesn't really
even notice or know what's going on but
I know you know and that becomes a big
question about art if you do something
that's important and extremely involved
in pushing yourself and making something
beautiful happen but no one will know it
should you do it or should you cheat
because no one will know that you're
cheating either the tough decision have
to be be hard on yourself to really make
and I do that all the time and sometimes
yes like you mean you know I tell people
about it almost cuz maybe sometimes I
feel like you know it's if I'm gonna go
through all this trouble now I would
kinda want people to know that how much
trouble will go if it's guys stupid I
was like it it becomes a different
battle yeah but how do you want to say
this is a plastic guitar from the Sears
& Roebuck catalog or whatever in 1965
and the strings are 4 inches from the
fretboard and it is a monster to
play and but that is you like the
struggle yeah you like yeah I mean I
heard I think it was in your documentary
great white north we talked about you
the great rock cliche or visual cliche
as all the pics taped to the stands that
you can just grab one right pic breaks
or you lose it you just grab another one
you keep the pics back so you literally
have to walk back and get another pic
and then I heard you say that I thought
that seems Catholic okay yeah
flagellation she just in between chords
flagellate yourself it's in the back and
then a few more but that's the sense I
got it is man I don't I don't know but I
know it feels uh uh I'm feels like I'm
getting somewhere
I know that was tough move to do I was
watching uh when my daughter
she's like six years old scarlet out the
other day and she's starting getting
there WC Fields now I'm watching my
probably my one of my favorites really
maybe maybe maybe my favorite next to
it's like Marx Brothers WC Fields but WC
Fields fantastic well short of that the
one with the Carla Fong you know then in
a bed and then she's explaining why it
why does he keep saying Carla Fong and
spelling the whole thing I think it's
funny that you know he's making such a
big deal to spill this name out and talk
about this damn name
over and over again yeah you know and
you know trying to know at the age of
six just been planning this an idea and
bred that there's in her brain that uh
that you know there's seeds to things in
the future she'll understand that that
uh why think how things are constructed
but you know she was she was watching
this one where he's doing jugni oh he
did a routine he's juggling no cigar
boxes right you know taking the middle
and flipping it and that and I flashed
back for a second of my dad showed me
that when I was a kid too and we were
watching and he was laughing and at the
end he just looked over me and said try
it sometime Wow and I thought he's right
it looks really easy but that took a lot
of work and then took a lot of
determination to care enough to think
that I mean you gotta hand it to those
guys juggler the street performers I
mean those guys work really hard and
what they're doing in their complices
dealers and all the books all movies and
documentaries and all the stuff that are
made about the people that we are
interested in or we think that
accomplished something amazing you know
who wants to hear that they took the
easy way out all right who wants to hear
that they're just that cheated nobody
wants to hear that you know and we were
talking about you know as told you I was
watching these Larry Bird clips like
4:00 in the morning couple weeks ago
first God knows whatever reason but I
didn't I just didn't know much about him
um and they how how hard on himself he
was you know everyone else like I think
McHale or something set on the team you
know at the end of the night hey me and
I go home I got a life you know he's
going back out and popping
three-pointers in the empty arena by
himself he would do it in the off season
yeah French Lick he had a he had a hoop
yeah he would just shoot over and over
and over again in his spare time and
it's funny because I'm just listening to
the people you reference across the
spectrum you know whether it's in music
whether it's in comedy like a WC Fields
or a Steve Martin Johnny Carson there's
a common thread which is they all
prepared it's all preparation yeah and I
you know you can sound like an old man
but it's not fun to tell I tell when
young people ask me I'd like to do what
you're doing or I'm interested in what
you how do I do that it's not fun but I
have to tell them you have to work
really hard and you always have to
prepare
and you have to have your together
and really have it locked down it's not
a fun and then go into a situation and
when you've done that then that gives
you the freedom to throw it out the
window and play but it's not a fun
message and in there and it's going to
get worse because the technology that's
available now is is all about as
technology has always been making things
less labor-intensive and removing the
labor from the from this whatever thing
it is whatever idea it is so as
technology gets more and more down the
line of you don't need to sing in tune
we can sing in tune for you press this
button and it will tune you I mean it's
going to get worse and worse and it's up
to every I have a big chip on my
shoulder about responsibility for
technology you know when the telephone
first came out people learn telephone
etiquette you know when people actually
said Hawaii Hawaii boy boy yeah Hoya no
I stay you know there was telephone
etiquette it was a politeness a new kind
of politeness not just taking politeness
from the parlor and put it on to this
device it was a new kind of politeness
because you couldn't see the other
person and I think there were for a long
time technology went even victrolas you
know how how that was done there was a
manners and politeness that were
attached to it responsibility for the
new technology but I think nowadays I
think the new technologies here give me
the toy and I you know I don't give a
damn anything to do with anything rules
no rules about the toy at all just give
me the toy meaning we're out to dinner
right now and I could spend the whole
time with this Blackberry doing this and
going huh-huh-huh and not paying any
attention to you but the whole concept
of going out to dinner and having a
social you know it's when the restaurant
was first invented you think about that
you just imagine that restaurants always
exist yeah but apparently restaurants
someone invented the idea of what's
going to eat and you can have dinner I
mean people had gone to taverns before
but a restaurant and when people first
went to restaurants it was thought to be
very rude to have other people seeing
you eat that was thought of his rude
something we don't think at all about
anymore but that was thought of his rude
strangers shouldn't see you putting food
in your mouth so they had to separate
people and have them in both
behind curtains and things a road things
a road and now you can imagine a
McDonald's where there's curtains they
can get you big men we don't behind a
curtain but we don't see a we don't hear
any talk at all about it only like as
jokes of people being rude with it but
whatever that's just how things go
nowadays you're not going to stop the
monster you know
the snowball they're rolling down but it
I'm believer that new technology means
new responsibility in art forms too if
you are photographer I mean you have
Photoshop now I mean now if you're gonna
call yourself refer and be one
and dedicate your life to that you have
a big monster hanging out in front of
you that can make you cheat on
everything contrast lighting aperture
everything you can cheat on everything
and it's your duty to decide how much
you're gonna let yourself fall down that
well because now if I show you a great
photograph it's beautiful
you know whenever thirty forty years ago
it was who took that photo how did that
happen how did he capture that moment
right and now it's it's probably fake
it's probably altered to look that
probably an Ansel Adams app take
something of your iPhone and push it and
then it's just every bit as good some
people will say who would care so what
the image is great it's two-dimensional
anyways what does it matter how it was
created but to be a photographer and
dedicate yourself to that you have to
really be able to live with yourself
that you know that just taking the easy
way out like that through technologies
is not always fulfilling either you you
mentioned image and it's funny because
it's a quote that you have in a scene
that really struck me in a documentary
we may go through Canada and at one
point you said one of your reviews that
you liked the most and you'll you
remembered better than I do is I think
someone said you know white stripes and
we're simultaneously the most real and
most fake bed in the most yeah and I
think you said fake first real second
most faith and most and and because of
that most real band in the world and I
thought that as a fascinating statement
you know obviously you've you play with
image
you play with how things look it's very
important to you and yet mostly what
we've talked about here for a long time
is stripping things of ornamentation
when you actually do the work
oh we crazy contract I love I'd loves it
to fix you know extrapolate would you
call it
there's no extrapolating here I love
dix-huit we don't have the equipment for
very expensive it's like spelunking yeah
that is a beautiful point of how when we
start the white shows for example I
still do it now and we did when we were
on your shoulder today you know there's
for me the easy way out is to go up in
jeans in a t-shirt and and but what's
what comes along with that is a
generation for last you know 20 30 or
however years since Punk that that type
of dress was considered real you were
real you weren't the the you know soul
review you weren't the you know the
Beatles dressed up on its Elvin whatever
you were real because you were in jeans
and t-shirt and that choice was also the
same choice that tons of other people
are making they're all making that
choice when they walk on stage you make
it you have to make it choice
you can go into what you slept in last
night or you can dress up in a suit or
something like that but the idea that
that became authenticity that that gives
you a license of authenticity always
bugged me and when Megan I were starting
we're playing blues music and you know
this is the music that is closest to our
hearts and I started rapping on these
other ideas that you know the best way
to show how real this is this music is
is to give them an artifice a
presentation that's all the aesthetic is
all red white and black and it's
presented to them that if someone went
walk into that bar and say this is
look at this oh this is a real
blues band the brother and sister she's
in pigtails yet peppermints paint on
everything I mean this is but whatever
but that was are the same people you I
don't want to connect with I don't want
to share with them because they can't
see past that and that's like the
ultimate test you know if you couldn't
see past that and realize that this
music is actually ultra real and full of
mistakes messed up you know and at least
attempting to try to get down to
something dirty you know and I I don't
want I don't want to use the word
authentic because I think authenticity
is
a trap and I think I think it think it's
a waste of time everybody's time and
authenticity in music has been something
that everyone's chased you know for a
long time there's these different
periods of music you know where you know
the big band periods or Eva coup stick
music periods into big band periods
country music soo ultra produce things
now computerized music digital music
where you know people of all so yeah but
that's not the real deal you I like this
person yeah but he's not the real deal
this guy is the real deal
and you have to decide for yourself what
that means you know what's like it you
know in whatever in 19 I'm gonna say 68
69 in music everything's gotten
psychedelic everything started to and
then the band comes along yeah and
everyone decides now we've got all you
know get back to what's real but people
but then people realize things drift
again and who's to say what's real
so there are everyone's trying to get
back to what they think is the real
roots music what music what music is
your favorite music what's type what
genre or kind of you know it's funny cuz
I I was imagine that it's rockabilly as
you're famous right right yeah
rockabilly was wet grabbed me completely
I don't come from a musical family at
all and I wasn't particularly I was
really interested in music but resisted
anyone trying to teach me anything and
then I was in college I'm going to this
Ivy League college and I'm I'm it hit me
I son session Elvis Presley got
rereleased
which and then I was started listening
to Jerry Lee Lewis I got the the poster
in my room in college was Jerry Lee
Lewis on the flatbed from High School
Confidential and I got hit hard and I
didn't know what the hell I was doing
but just started seeing it I had been a
bad drummer like a pretty mediocre
drummer but I was passionate about
drumming at a really crappy set I bought
the cheapest that I could gags I didn't
have a lot of money I got a court
and I've asked people all over the world
have you ever heard of a courtly no
one's heard of it but I still have it
it's what they made like three of them
and then said we're not a drum company
sort of meeting radiators or something
but and then I when I got out to LA it
was just in me and I went and got a $90
guitar at freedom guitar and got the Mel
Bay chord book nice and just sat there
for a long time and when I was a young
comedy writer and single and had no
girlfriend I just used to go home every
night from whatever show I was working
on and I would sit there with the TV on
and for six hours straight teach myself
chords but what really grabbed me was
rockabilly and it's so visceral yeah and
just like the original train kept
a-rollin it was just it's borderline
unpleasant that's what I thought but I'm
I've always been I don't know it's some
kind of intensity to it yeah and I wish
and I never really got much beyond that
I mean I always try to get more
sophisticated about my playing and it
always just snaps back and I have my my
real outlet I mean the thing that you do
finds you more than you find it I love I
loved that very much and I was in high
school I I got into surf music and
rockabilly music and I was going to see
any of those kind of bands I could and
after a while a little bit of me started
to lose the attention for um you know
the the the stylistic people who were
trying to be like retro and recreate a
moment in time it's gone and dressed
that way yeah it's like it's kind of
nice for a party or Halloween or
something like that but to dedicate your
lifestyle to this one moment in the me
right culture history this one year is
it's nifty in one way but another way I
thought well it's a dead end I mean you
can't explore that music in a bigger way
as a songwriter you know I got a guy
listen to Gene Vincent to this day and
I'll listen to the day I die I love him
yeah um and I play his music and I've
covered his songs and stuff and
but uh it's like everything in e yeah
everything is in E that's what I liked
Izzy's great and but he and he had one
of the great guitar players the homie on
a cliff galloping cliff gallop you it's
funny cuz you always talk about how your
maybe your favorite song is by son house
yeah
written in your face yeah I was always
surprised by that because I appreciate
it but it's almost like that was your a
religious light that hit you when you
heard grinning in your face but that's
when you listen to it it's so primal
it's very simple
yeah handclaps you know yeah well you
know there's the message that's in it
too besides how how it was recorded and
how it sounded from him now his
handclaps are often I'm even with his
there's no music behind it it's several
things at once its blues it's like a
work song it's a religious song it's
it's a song that's from one person
against the world one person against his
own friends and family which is sort of
the you know I bet you know a hallmark
of the Blues you know but I think even
the message more stuff was probably
something that has always bugged me when
out since I was a kid and probably will
always bug me later on is how much do
you care what other people think I mean
like the comedian on stage you tell the
joke and nobody laughs um you have to
take another step a new step you can
cower and fall down and die from it you
can you can let it affect you that way
or you can let it push you to do
something new and move forward to
something positive which I think God is
also curses that we can't really enjoy
the good moment to after that at times
which is a shame but yeah I don't know
what I've learned is I'm very good at
hating the bad moment and terrible and
enjoying the good news yeah I can have
nine good news oh and I have the bad
moment and I savor it I like ladle
myself like it's like I'm its gravy and
I'm poor and I spent a long time making
everyone around me suffer and I suffer
and and then they say like you just had
nine great shows why are you focusing on
this one and I think I don't know cuz it
feels good to hate myself
[Laughter]
it's not fair though I was also like
when you there was something good does
happen and you try to enjoy it in a way
if you enjoy it too much you fall in the
traps of being egotistical or something
like that or people around you just
being turned off by your own love of
something good that happened to you
and so there's this extremely narrow
window when you create things and make
things that didn't exist that you have
to live in which is very hard to do
because to create a balance you know to
know it that wasn't that wasn't working
that was in the bad world that worked
that was in the good world and how much
you let other people around you your
friends and family see of how much that
affects you what people thought of that
what people thought of that and how all
you can do is to let it push you forward
and just take everything like even-keel
like that was bad that was good that my
brother was gone okay so here's a trap
because you've had a lot of critical
acclaim yeah you are
at times in well I would say fairly
consistently you know I mean you
probably can search out the negative
because that's that but from my point of
view you more than most everybody I know
in in your field has had a lot of
musical has a lot of has had a great
deal of critical acclaim and then the
danger becomes I like it I like people
liking me for sure we've all been there
it's really nice to be liked and then
when you do something that isn't so
popular it doesn't you can tell yourself
I need to endure people not liking me to
do the good work yeah but it feels
really good as it is it's a dangerous
zone yeah
stages and it's it's not fair that it's
dangerous it should be climbing up the
mountain and you're at the top of the
mountain of whatever and okay you you
you you did what it took you didn't you
didn't cheat and take a helicopter to
the top of mountain you really climbed
up the top of the mountain but when you
get up there doesn't matter if you took
the helicopters and mad if you climbed
and got all bloody from it
the rewards up there are fleeting and
they don't really have legs they they're
just they're fleeting and you can't hold
onto
them right all the people won't let you
hold on to them really III it's it's
it's I mean try to do it I mean try to
talk about yourself and a good thing
that happened to you for more than ten
seconds I heard a run I had a really
funny story about um Arthur Miller I
don't know if it's true but I think
let's pretend it's true okay because
this is for the internet it doesn't
matter um but I think Arthur Miller once
said that when he first wrote Death of a
Salesman everyone said oh my god you're
a genius
he wrote Death of a Salesman and then
everything else he wrote people said
it's good but it's no Death of a
Salesman and then at the end of his
career they said you know does the
salesmen wasn't that great it's like no
I if you're I don't know if you're
looking for that II ever written what do
you think is sadder story a Death of a
Salesman or Lord of the Flies mmm I
gotta go with Laurel if I just have a
real when people taunt a heavy person
I'm serious it I can't watch a movie
where a heavy person is taunted and I
don't know why I'm how about the actors
they hired to play the person to get
anything I I audition go that seems
really awkward I get like I I can't do
it I can't watch Gilbert Grape I can't I
won't watch Gilbert great for that
reason right um have you seen the movie
the documentary the fog of war yes
Robert McNamara yep yeah I'm in
transferred I think I've watched that
six times now what is it about the fog
of war that someone just said you should
check this out and I turned it on and on
I don't even know I never I knew nothing
about Robert McNamara and I never see
even seen a picture of him and I thought
I know pretty fair amount of your
history and stuff but I just didn't know
any bottom you know um and then he was
president of Ford Motor Company and then
he became Secretary of Defense I think
the idea at the time and Camelot was we
can hire incredibly smart young people
and they'll solve all the world's
problems
yeah so and you think about when you're
from Detroit's you understand if you if
you think about an auto executive in
1960 how they were gods you know right
so and he was this brilliant guy and
so he comes into the Kennedy
administration and they bring him in you
know he continues Lyndon Johnson begs
everyone to stay so he stays with
Johnson and then he ends up running this
war which is a colossal mistake and he
eventually realizes that and so it's
yeah that that documentary is really
poignant because if brilliant but he's
also like a dad it's almost like you
took someone's dad on a 50s block and
put him in these most powerful positions
in the world I mean he was so heavily
involved in the Cuban Missile Crisis
which really we came so close to the
world ending at that point and also Ford
Motor Company and safety and introducing
safety ideas to cars which Tucker had
tried to do it failed and and it's these
people like that that are so important
to world history that not that many
people even know their names or saw the
pictures like I didn't know that his
name so how did you get I mean was it
you're watching are you watching The
History Channel like when you're trying
to just yeah relax what are you watching
I really do enjoy documentaries I could
read encyclopedia all day long I prefer
books that are about things that really
happen yes yeah you know I'm always my
wife uh loves fiction she's very smart
and she's constantly and she's reading
great fiction my wife is repot earns
well the really good Harry Potter yeah
yeah the Sorcerer's Stone but she's the
classics you know not this whatever yeah
later stuff that I think really
perverted Harry's nature but she my wife
is a I think she's really brilliant and
she's constantly reading like I'll you
know be getting ready for bed and she's
in bed reading she shouldn't check off
you know she's famous great stuff and
she'll be saying you know you should
read this and I'll say you know what I
life is too short and I want to know
what happened so I almost exclusively
read you said she has ever you said that
and I said that I said I want to know
what yeah yeah yeah I want to know what
happened I want to know and and so I'm
constantly getting you know there's a
picture of me someone took in the 90s
where I finally went on a vacay
and I'm sitting on the teach and and
it's like beautiful like Anguilla or
something I'm sitting on the beach and
I'm course I'm wearing like 900 sunblock
but I'm sitting on the beach and it's
beautiful and it's his color photograph
and I'm reading the rise and fall of the
Third Reich a swastika on it and it's
this thick and I'm like ah vacation you
know I'm reading about you know the
failed Russian offensive I just asthma
what do you think of a Lincoln movie I
really love the Lincoln movie and since
this is the zone to be incredibly honest
I love the Lincoln movie I thought it
was fantastic I love Daniel day-lewis
because he portrayed the real Lincoln
down to every single actors ever
portrayed Lincoln has done him with his
deep baritone was gone
yeah Lincoln had a high-pitched voice
and I thought he just made me love I
love Lincoln know way too much about
Lincoln and I thought he was brilliant
yeah there were a couple things I wish
the movie had ended I don't want they
had to kill the Lincoln character off at
the end they didn't you know that was
the same thing I thought there's a part
in the movie where Lincoln says he's got
to go to the theater and he has this
line he says well gentlemen I'd like to
stay no he said I have to go though I'd
like to stay and then there's a long
walk off so if the movie had ended there
I'd have cried for seven days I didn't
need to then like we know what happened
and I thought that would have been more
beautiful and I have calls into
Spielberg and he's not as good it was
cool that they showed a performance in a
theater and Lincoln's son to make you
even think that that might have been I
mean I guess I mean at least I didn't
show bloody like yeah but uh but I say I
agree with what you're saying I thought
that would have been a nice way to end
it and I was literally in the lobby
telling people that like why is Conan
O'Brien but you got a trailer threw me
off I thought that when I saw the
Lincoln trail like oh man I thought this
was gonna be great and I saw the trailer
I just thought damn it it ain't like
it's too like they got all the
components they got the great costume
designers or the set directors and all
that stuff and everything's there but
it's not gonna be what I thought it was
gonna be but the trailer was wrong I
went in and then you know 20 minutes I
thought this is really good all right
well this brings up a good area you are
an opinionated guy you like having
control as do I is it hard for you to
watch things and step back and enjoy
them and experience them without editing
them in your mind and moving them around
like you're you know you've seen a movie
and you're thinking no that's not what I
would do or you're listening to a band
or you're yeah what happens well I know
I like something when I don't notice how
it was made if I see the scene yeah if I
hear a song and I don't like oh they
turned to reverb on on that part of the
song or they added a digital delay on
his voice or something or they kind of
borrowed that lick yeah when I heard
them when I when I hear them what their
conversation was making it bugs me then
I kind of I can't enjoy it so much when
it goes by the scene goes by or the
painting or the the song goes by and you
don't even notice anything about how it
was made at then I think that's a really
good mark of something good that's hard
to get to that point too I mean sorry to
create something like that let's talk
about if you don't mind this I went to
Third Man Records
and got to make a record with you which
is still one of my the tour and then
that experience one of my favorite
experiences in my life that allows
treasure
people later on ask me what's it like a
third man records and I thought this is
tough and I I said you know jack is
incomplete I've never met anyone and I
mean this is a compliment who has
completely invented his environment
you've you've created an environment out
of whole cloth for yourself and at first
I was thinking it's kind of like an Andy
Warhol thing where you've created you
know the factory and you've created this
aesthetic and this group of people and
this look and this tribal you know
happening and then I thought you know
what it's really a Batman villain like
you've you know whenever you're like
whether it's mr. freeze or the Riddler
or the Joker what I always loved about
Batman the TV classic TV show is he
always got his people to wear musical
notes or did the Riddler hired guys he
went and found common criminals and he
got them to wear turtlenecks that have a
question mark on them and he also got
them
to buy into the Riddler's aesthetic and
it was beat it was beautiful
and I thought like this let's talk about
that I got it to me that is a great
achievement well thank you and I feel
good I feel proud that you're saying
that to me because I I know that third
man it came the way a lot of lot of
times the way I make things which is
it's sort of they're these happy
accidents I stumble into it and I and it
gets pushed in these baby steps and
something in the end says oh wow that
thing exists now and that building I
bought was just a place to store my gear
I didn't have a I was renting all these
storage units for all the tour gear when
come open to her after all this drums
and amps and stuff somewhere I was like
empty nice to just have a building where
it was all there and was on racks and I
could get that keyboard or that guitar
and take it a studio not buried away in
some storage and we need a padlock and
it's nighttime in the flashlights are
you gonna keep yeah somewhere it's
available that's all I want to do that
building and then I thought well you
know it'd be nice I got the White
Stripes vinyl rights back
that's the years at the time period been
used up and now I can print them and
they were out of print so I don't like
records being out of print I think it's
kind of ridiculous I think record should
always be in print of it was like if
Columbia Records put out some record by
any artist you should always have a
stack of them on a shelf somewhere even
if there's 10 of them you know right and
get so I thought well you know I want to
put the white straight old vinyl records
in print and keep them in print forever
neither hired a couple these guys the
bends to do that so that was it was
gonna be it and I said oh you know let's
put a store in the front is a little
room in front let's put a little store
there and people can bit ring the buzzer
maybe once a week someone come by and
well we'll come up and we'll sell em a
45 you know that'll happen like once a
week antha and then baby 7 and then
we're here to put a photo studio back so
it'd be nice to be able to rehearse for
tour here for lighting and monitors to
put a stage there and as you know you
ended up playing a live show at that
stage that became a live venue and now
we have a lathe cutting studio behind
that stage where we cut this the shows
direct to acetate which is the only
place in live venue in the world that's
doing that it goes directly to vinyl
when the crowd can see through the
window what's happening and they're
completely involved and they feel they
know what's happened you're making a
record here it's almost like a TV show
now making this live record so this is
all just from place I wanted to get my
gear so it was like letting things natch
happen you know this feels like the
story of your whole process because to
go way back to the caveman days the
caveman days when you discovered fire
with your friend dog
nothing good good good really good guy
really pay that you had to crush his
skull the handmade stone to know what
what um you know I remembered I don't
know if I read somewhere you told me
somewhere when you were just starting
out and you're playing with Meg you were
thinking hey if we could just get up on
stage and play in front of people yeah
so that would be cool and what happens
is it's a constant upping of the ante
yeah which is I you know if I could just
get on stage and play and we could get a
few people to come see us I'd be happy
if we could just have a couple more
songs if we could have a few more gigs
if we could make a record if we could
tour if we could okay now we've got one
smash record if we could have another
one if we could you know the Grammys if
we could tour the world if we could make
a documentary it's a never-ending
upping of the ante and now you're
talking about you know if we could have
a space where we're making the records I
mean you've taken it to that extreme and
a lot of musicians though though you say
a band like that will do that like we'll
be good if we had a band if you're great
if it got on stage what if we wrote our
own songs they get to that point not to
get someone to say yeah you know I got
to go back to my day job and we got to
do that thing and we'll play another gig
next month and then you know then gone
they they lose the either the ability or
the desire to push themselves over and
over and over and over again and that's
the only thing you can really do you can
also you can get lucky you could have
some lucky break or something and it
catapults you to some level and then you
have some decisions to make up there but
in the natural way of things if you if
you you you basically have moments where
you can stop and say like we said about
McHale and Larry Bird really like you
know hey I have a life man I mean you
can say that at any moment say hey yeah
I like music but you know I'm not gonna
spend 24 hours a day thinking about it
but you know that that's what comes from
that if you if there's no pushing
I think you know we were saying earlier
that all the idols that we've had people
we are interested in from the past I
think they're all seem to be people who
push and push and push and I can imagine
even if you were home
they had no talented anything and no
ability to bring anything to life not
funny not what interesting or whatever
even if you pushed yourself at work
constantly at it something would happen
I mean how could it not and something
eventually would click yeah no I you
know you didn't doubt where you're
supposed to be or what what zone you're
supposed to be and you know maybe I'm
not supposed to be acting maybe is
supposed to be a community I'm not
supposed to you're musician must be a
painter at some point something would
click I think pushing yourself that much
here's the good news and the bad news I
can look at a guy like David Letterman
and say well why isn't he happy because
he really achieved everything but I know
that there are some people who were 20
years younger than me who are like
what's you know why would he be unhappy
because he you know and you think nobody
feels that way nobody feels like they
have their done nobody feels like
they're done nobody I mean there's like
a mixture of never arrived I don't think
you ever around ever arrived and also I
don't know like I want to bring up
uh-huh
anger or sometimes people say to me like
you seem like I can get cranky I can get
angry and I say yeah I just think that's
part of this spice that keeps me going i
if I was completely contented that would
be it but anger seems to anger and
frustration seems to be necessary
components I think the minute you don't
have those yeah if you're eliminate all
these other emotions you're sort of like
I mean it's sort of in a way it's sort
of easy to be a nice guy and be like
happy-go-lucky and say hey yeah you know
and but maybe that kind of attitude it's
harder for it to get things done and get
things accomplished and get things to
happen and push yourself if you don't
eat a lot all those other emotions to
exist I I haven't think that the society
is missing out on something right now to
think that anger and hostility are
things that are in the violent realm of
emotions that they're all completely
100% bad and should be avoided at all
costs I don't think that's true at all I
mean
that those emotions are very much
relevant and say blues music they're
very much relevant in painting you know
and rock-and-roll punk rock all that I
mean those are if they'd ignored those
emotions and not thought about them and
express them and they wouldn't have they
wouldn't be able to explore those ideas
and again I almost happy-go-lucky 'no
siz sort of like I was saying icon stage
you can be like I'm enjoying this song
feels great this feels good you know
it's a smile on my face um this is a
blast okay that's kind of easy to do I
survived having a party you know you can
be like a heavy metal band and they'll
be partying and you know and then I
don't know if that's art or music it's
just maybe something else it's another
name there's got to be something inside
you that's churning it up there has to
be that's got to be part of the creative
process it's there self-inflicted wounds
you know I mean you're that's the
responsibility that comes with freedom
you know freedom of to be an artist
that's it that's a huge freedom and at
the same time has to be a huge
responsibility or there nothing will be
accomplished and it's not fair to other
people you know it's like the lazy so
and so whatever we're just sitting
around in the other people his roommates
or keeping them alive and keep giving
him shelter and all that stuff you know
like you can get away with that for a
minute but after a while you know
everyone else is like hey man you know
we're not all here to just take care of
you you know you have to take care of
yourself and um I think those those
those are really heightened in in the
world of art and creativity you you have
to think about all those things I
sometimes I think too much about that
about the temptations to take there's
easy ways that out all the time because
I see other people doing out there oh
damn I mean even to show other people
other musician of my studio and say we
did this song and this is how we did it
and this is the Machine we did it on
these are tools we did it with and have
another musician look at and say okay
well yeah well we know we just recorded
our album and we did it totally the easy
way and we didn't record our Pro Tools
and I had these four engineers do it and
they fixed everything on and it's coming
out next week
like there's a first thing like damn man
I guess I could do that I could do that
and no one would even know and one would
even know I did it that way and I could
did I can't be can't do it thank you I
hate to beat a dead horse but I swear to
god there's like a religious was I
Catholic component too I would know yeah
yeah you know to me I feel that way
about comedy you can when you cheat you
know it and it doesn't it feels horrible
and if something's good happens you want
it to be it was created under
circumstances you can be proud of it's
not uh you know something that was like
someone else did the work or a computer
did the work or something like that the
photographer I was talking about earlier
if someone's at all amazing photo you
tip well we photoshopped the whole thing
yeah can you be proud of that
I can't I guess you can but I wouldn't
be proud of it
um you I think more than anybody I can
think of your music off the top of my
head you work so well with women Meg hmm
Alison Mosshart Amy current band
phenomenal jr. yeah Dame Judi Dench the
music that you cut with her in that
erotic film you made you guys what it
what do I find women so attractive is
all you're trying to ask me yeah cuz I
don't get it I like men I like in me and
I wasn't even like a naked male body
sometimes the the sunsets that we spend
together in a parked car on top of a
hill sometimes wonder if that's how
you're me when I try and hold your hand
yeah then pretend I'm reaching for the
gear shoes yeah awesome I wonder um I'm
fine yeah but you've you working with
women here so you're you just it comes
so naturally to you and I think it's it
you don't I don't see other musicians
and artists making that connection as
easily as you I don't know if you've
never given it any thought
like how is it that I I communicate so
well with women it's a it's an
interesting question in my in my mind
like when asked Cole
you know it feels like I don't
discriminate in any way you know age
race gender at all I just work with
people that are cooking and they're
making them pushing themselves you've
never worked with a baby I've not yet
not hey baby I hate I hate you very very
it they're so lazy but uh consummate
just say themselves but that's my
biggest complaint with you is your anti
baby ism right but you're here so you're
say you're not thinking about it well
that's what I would add that something
answer in my head that seems pretty
clean an answer but then I know there's
other things too that when I am working
with women I do feel that there's this
sense something's gone out the window
there's some there's a lot of
that's been thrown away and now we're
getting down to the real creativity in
the real work and maybe working with men
no matter how clean it's going on
there's always maybe some kind of
competition or ego or other qualities in
the room that you can't put your finger
on which everything has to be filtered
through so for some reason the females I
go with Loretta Lynn or you know at
least your keys or something they didn't
actually want a Jackson date it seems
like that just goes out the window and
we we get down to the work faster so I
do I definitely think there's is an
appeal to it for me and we become very
equal very fast and on the same page
very fast someone tell me one time like
it was some goofy thing I had too much I
wasn't something I read an article about
it must have been some computing about
dating or guys being getting women
interested in them and it was something
like you know women women like to be
shown things so they women like to be
taught things excuse me we like to be
taught new things I thought that's this
interesting thing is to single out
females that they like to be taught new
things don't we all like to be look
don't we all like to learn new things I
think about this all the time I don't
know that's actually something that's do
you think do you find anything about
that statement I don't know no I mean
I'm still and I'm the word completely
mystified by women to this day and I
have been obsessed with them since I was
like six and and
took you how long it took me till six
yeah I was I was bye till I was six um
but I but I was uh yeah I don't I know
that there's a completely different
dynamic when you're working with women
which can be fantastic and comedy gets
this reputation for being completely
sexist which is I think well-earned and
then over the years and then I whenever
I've worked with Tina Fey or an Amy
Poehler or Sarah Silverman their sex has
you don't even think about it
mm-hm do you not I mean right if you're
thinking about it there's something else
at play yeah when you're working there's
so many brilliant women comics and
writers out there and it just doesn't
come into play you just admire them
let's like that's great they're they're
great and you want to try and impress
them yeah you know with maybe I could be
as funny as you it's also a new era that
may be the first in history maybe in a
way that men and women can work together
in a way that is totally acceptable to
accomplish the task at hand you know
maybe it wasn't a hundred years ago to a
man and a woman to be in a room together
working on something by themselves would
have been what he were what were you
doing you are working alone with this is
quite improper yeah you know or even
taking it all the way back in some other
biological way of you know the that I
wonder what that was like you know
thousands of years ago but um but you
what you said earlier was I reminded me
that it is something let's say I would
work with Loretta Lynn and things would
be working in cooking and beautiful
things are happening and then later on
it's a lot you know she's not only a
woman she's an older woman you know been
twice my age with whatever it is and why
is it working so easily we've come from
two different worlds completely but for
some reason in the room it's making
complete sense and there's something
I've learned a lot about that about just
relationships outside of that between me
and women that that there's a lot to be
learned from that that relationships in
a
or marriage and they there's something
to be learned from that we're always
working together I really enjoy you're
always working with the other person to
get somewhere I think people have an
ideal that maybe getting a marriage or
getting a Russian ship or marriages you
know having a wedding or something and
then it flat it stays flat and stays
peaceful for the rest of your life you
find a comfort zone it's just peaceful
but it's not true it's constant work
again you have to keep throwing fuel on
the fire to keep it alive and keep it
you know I'm Albert Einstein said that
marriage is an attempt at making
something lasting out of an incident and
I think he's right I think you know
all's I hated that saying she hated that
it's like it's this the crappiest
Hallmark card you ever said oh I always
mess it up yeah it's you know this
brings up another area which is just
idols like you working with a Loretta
Lynn or wanted Jackson working these
people and it's something I've
confronted where I really love it when
you forget that they're your idols and I
know I you were nice enough to have me
over to your house once and we're
sitting on your front porch and you were
talking about Bob Dylan then it felt
like you had gotten past the point of oh
my god it's Bob Dylan yeah do you know
what I mean in a good way
you obviously it's Bob Dylan but you're
not doing that artist a favor yeah when
you when you put someone on that kind of
pedestal you're killing them you put an
artist up there you're killing them so
they don't like to talk to them and meet
them and yeah let me feel like you have
that ability to I don't know even mean
I'm you were telling me oh yeah Bob
Dylan wants to do the welding on my
fence
yeah welding now I was yeah you know and
I was just like well that's great you
broke through the so what was it like to
record tangled up and be like you broke
through that yeah and got to I think I
can fix your game
yeah yeah well he's a mahine and he
knows I mean he's you know I've said it
before and he's like he's it is it like
my dad
meaning musically uh in my own mind and
the heritage that I feel like I jumped
in this running river already I just
jumped in you know that you know he's
like he's like a father to me
so much so that he I couldn't read his
book his autobiography I couldn't read
it I would I kept picking it up and I
would read ten pages and I had to put it
down like it was just too close and it
sounds crazy but it just it was too
close to me I couldn't take it it was
like reading a letter my own father had
written to me you know and I found it in
his closet after he died or something
like that and I took me I really like
three or four tries before I could
actually get through and read the book
it meant too much all the words because
it was like advice with the hand around
your shoulder advice that I knew when I
was reading them it was different for
people who are music fans or Dillon fans
or other musicians or something like
that it just was totally different for
me and to read those words they feel
like they're right there directly
pointed at me and and I started to get
obsessed with the fact that people are
misunderstanding the style that this is
written and they're misunderstanding the
point that's being made in this
paragraph and he does that a lot to me
like anything that he's doing you know
and it's a it's it's it's hard for you
to feel like that when you feel like
there isn't there is you know always an
al Bernard scent alive right now that
Bob Dylan's alive right now and that you
know that you that I can be that close
to him and that far apart from him at
the same time simultaneously
you never can you know in a lot of ways
get super close to somebody like that
that you don't have that much history
with you know probably it's not just you
though do you think anybody can get that
close I mean he's a notorious well for
to him - everybody out Burt and even for
anybody for any of your idols you know
I'm sure like you could maybe have had a
conversation with Johnny Carson and
learned a lot in 30 seconds and or even
hung out and stayed for a week with him
somewhere and and and but how close can
you get to Johnny Carson and
I don't know I mean I'm assuming that it
might be hard to break through that but
but you just take whatever you can get
because it's all it's a I arrived the
several conversations I had with Johnny
Carson in my life are embedded in there
are little diamonds in my brain and I
know I can remember the flashing light
on the phone when they said oh yeah he's
on that line and you know I remember the
light flashing and but you're right at
the same time I'll be the first to say I
knew him I didn't know him at all so and
it's funny cuz there's someone like
there's someone like Dylan who's
constantly you know you look at rock and
roll and I've had this thought before
which is there's only so many chords
there's a few chords there's a few and
you feel like there's got to be a limit
to but people like you can take this
it really is restricted I mean in a way
you know I mean there's not that many
you can take that palette and keep
coming up with new stuff I've had
periods of my life where I thought maybe
rock and roll is done maybe we've done
everything with e e a b7 maybe an
occasionally minor a my you know I mean
like maybe we've done it all yeah Bob
Dylan uh I don't know every you just
think of the simplicity of it nobody
Holly yeah I really know managed to get
off fun because I thought yeah
oh my god he really is just using three
chords occasionally a fourth chord but
it's the okay it's the pattern that he's
putting it down yeah it just it's so
simple and it's not - yeah he's he's
he's like he's sideswiping you you know
you used to throwing sand in your face
and then coming around from the back and
poking patting you on the back it it's
unbelievable about it Buddy Holly
accomplishes its song by song I mean you
know it's obviously I saw it's too bad
these people died and knowing we never
got to you know they would they have
done if they moved on but him especially
man they just
it's something peculiar about him
there's certain people like Michael
Jackson or buddy Howell you're Hank
Williams that are just they're like
aliens they weren't they weren't really
supposed to be here or something you
know that how do you born that way and
how do things connect with your brain
and come out your fingers in that way
and and if you catch a glimpse of it if
you if you're ever part of something
that's created that connects with
another human being or connects with
many human beings it's a very humbling
experience to even think that it's
possible you know that you can connect
with you know if you're going on to your
show and there's how many millions of
people watching that or will watch it on
the internet or something like that and
that means something I mean something
and it's it's unexplainable you can't
explain to it why it works or why it
happens you can you can try to explain
it but it's really hated I don't know
what other word but magical or something
like that but words to that effect that
that are it's what my point is when you
live inside of a new create every day
and I want to create every day that you
don't get to know why it works really
you don't really get to know you see it
working and you know it worked but you
don't really get to know why it worked
and I think maybe that's sometimes I'm
fascinated with certain science
scientific things because I think as
much as statements are made and papers
are printed and reported it and we a lot
of science they'll never know you know
we don't know why the Red Spot on
Jupiter really is being doing that that
storm you know why is it lasting for
hundreds even triol II know we can tell
you certain aspects about it but that's
pretty compatible to a lot of things you
like John knowing I like not knowing
it's beautiful bum me out
when I was a kid my brother Neal and I
were obsessed with the Titanic amazing
shift it like sailed off and then it
disappeared and no one ever saw it again
and people survived some people survived
and talked about what happened but no
one had he had conflicting stories and I
loved that and then they found it and
then they not only found it but they
mapped every quarter of an inch of it
yeah and I remember thinking oh
and then they told you in a
computer-generated way exactly how it
came apart and exactly what happened
yeah and I was disappointed because
there was something about sailing off
into the fog and there's something about
music that I like about you know I don't
know the magic of the old blues musician
who died young and was poisoned there's
only one there's two photographs of them
in existence and we don't know much I
don't want to know more than that I
think there's something beautiful about
that the romance of that is is it's
unbelievable and and you know a lot of
times I find myself whining and
complaining about the the generation
that I'm part of now because it's so
much tougher I mean if you imagine that
something amazing right now was it a
Leonardo da Vinci existed right now he
would be just inundated with people just
trying to exploit him on levels that he
would never have been bothered with a
few centuries ago right and and all
things that would be detrimental to him
you know in his genius and all that like
what about this too which is that you
had a period of time where you're in
Detroit which is an overlooked City
mm-hmm no there's not a lot of media
there yeah so you could cook for a while
yeah and what I have always said is
people ask me my complaint or not my
complaint cuz you live in the area you
live in but if the Beatles were around
today we'd be sick of them before they
ever got out of the cavern club if it'd
be a million YouTube video you don't I
mean there'd be no discovery and we had
to discover things that people you know
it's the but you can't teach you can't
you won't we won't be able to really
teach the masses in that way it's like
teaching everyone to recycle or
something like teaching everybody to
understand the importance of letting
something beautiful be right now watch a
show instead of pulling this up and
using proof and using some other thing
to your friends to prove something or
Twitter it or whatever it is right like
couldn't something beautiful just be
like that and that's that's the danger
of where we are right now and where
we're headed it's it's I hate to be
always be thinking about that but when
you do when you when you consume when
you're sitting there and you're
entertained or you're enjoying our
music and books and films you can have
different opinion when you're inside of
and you want to make it exist and you're
trying to help it exist and be an
antenna and make this thing stuff come
out you're more concerned with the fact
that the way people are getting it the
mediums and formats from which they're
getting it is diluting their romance of
it right you know and it's an exhausting
battle to fight off that nowadays well
there's too much data yeah we have
Terra's you know i BAM like Stooges in
the 1970 would have had three
photographs of them taken right and now
there's thousands of every band without
their or musician of their thousands of
photos you know you did not know what he
knew where the Stooges lived or where
what they were they did all day long or
anything like that and you know and now
sure Robert Johnson nobody know who is
do you know what that's that's where you
get myth yeah the thing that fuels myth
is lack of information I have a question
here Kelly
Mraz from Facebook asked what kind of
music do your kids listen to you try to
influence their musical tastes I I don't
I uh I don't ever force stuff on them I
just
at times exposed them to things and
sometimes they don't like it sometimes
they do and I'm always shocked at the
things they like that you know my
daughter likes Charlie Chaplin so much
it's just shocking to me they had heard
some Beatles songs started liking them
and I was driving from Detroit to
Nashville a few weeks ago and I said
well listen this record it was Sergeant
Pepper and I put it on in the car and I
handed them whatever it was the and they
could see the album cover and you know
they just looked at it so much and they
had so many questions about the album
government it was so beautiful
to just be on this Drive and to think
about Sergeant Pepper again which I
don't haven't thought about in whatever
I was a teenager and to talk about all
the faces on there how that was made why
they were making it when kids ask you
those questions you get to relive those
moments which is really beautiful you
know and so that yeah they listened to a
lots of things like that The Ramones The
Beatles that's great there's something
for me yeah they like that and um but
they also like which I like even more
importantly these novelty songs I like
things like crazy frog and those
songs because I think you know our
Monster Mash those those tracks are
really culturally important yeah yeah
Monster Mash is now fantastic and and if
a kid likes it it's a good it's it's a
cut-through they are lying and they know
I wish we could talk for about four more
years I think that would be detrimental
to both our careers so I gotta end it
thanks for thanks for talking me like
the dishes the fresh air this has been
the fantastic I mean I thoroughly
enjoyed every second of our chat and the
drinking helped that'll do it for this
episode of serious jibber jabber to say
I thank Jack white would be the
understatement of the century
you've always been such a good friend to
me and such oh it's but such a pure
spirit too and so likewise really
appreciate that congratulations on all
your success I wish you happiness but I
know that's detrimental to your art but
I won't see all the other episodes of
serious jibber jabber go to team
koco.com slash serious or go to Conan's
house and he'll reenact them hi well
you're all invited to my home and I will
reenact these with little cutouts on
popsicle sticks for $20 a pop if you
ever need me to do the soundtrack for
any of that stuff just let me know
really yeah so we really opposed to my
furniture yes you heard it here you look
into that back camera now looking at
this one huh uh-huh there's nothing
shifty than guys looking at different
cameras